das ist wirklich wie aus einem
science-fiction-film die esa hat einen
neuen revolutionären antrieb für
raumfahrzeuge entwickelt dabei nutzt er
die luftmoleküle der oberen atmosphäre
vom planeten und ermöglicht so erheblich
längere raummissionen wieder mal einen
themenvorschlag der über whatsapp
reinkam da seid ihr wirklich absolut
hammer fantastisch tausend dank wie er
da auch mitmachen könnt erfahrt ihr am
ende des videos also wie der antrieb
funktioniert und was das für die
raumfahrt bedeutet jetzt den klicks und
science fiction herzlich willkommen es
hat kaum jemand mitbekommen aber die esa
ist was antriebe für raumfahrzeuge mit
dieser technologie angeht ganz weit
vorne sie hat bereits in ihrem coach
gravitations satelliten einen
elektrischen antrieb eingesetzt der
satellit hatte die aufgabe anomalien im
gravitationsfeld der erde aufzuspüren
denn die erdbeschleunigung von 98 1
meter pro sekunde im quadrat ist nicht
überall gleich und er suchte zusätzlich
nach energiequellen wärmequellen unter
der erdoberfläche die für geothermie
genutzt werden können die mission war
ein voller erfolg auch dank eines
elektrischen strahltriebwerke statt wie
bei chemischen triebwerken üblich
treibstoffe zu verbrennen ionisiert
dieser antrieb xenon moleküle durch die
elektrische ladungen können diese
moleküle dann mit elektrischen feldern
beschleunigt und ausgestoßen werden es
entsteht an rückstoß ein bisschen so wie
bei der alten fernseher röhre hier waren
es der elektronen die mithilfe von
kathode und anode auf eine bildfläche
geschossen wurden bei dem luftschlag
zwischen antritt sind es moleküle die in
den weltraum geschossen werden vorher
werden sie noch komprimiert um einen
deutlich stärkeren rückstoß zu erzeugen
doch bisher war für diese technologie
immer noch ein treibstoff nötig im fall
der große mission waren es 40 kilogramm
xenon die zum einen transportiert werden
mussten also gewicht und dann auch noch
irgendwann verbraucht waren
der satellit stürze zurück auf die erde
und verglühte in höhe der falkland
inseln vor argentinien vollständig ende
der mission
doch jetzt hat die esa einen prototypen
getestet bei dem das nicht mehr
passieren muss kutsche flog nämlich
lediglich in einer höhe von 250
kilometern über der erde eine höhe in
der der antrieb dazu benutzt wird um vor
allem eine gegenkraft gegen den geringen
luftwiderstand in der dünnen atmosphäre
dort zu erzeugen und es gibt zahlreiche
raumfahrzeuge die so tief fliegen um
ihre aufgaben erfüllen zu können auch
die ssd internationale raumstation
umkreist die erde in einer höhe von
lediglich 400 kilometern
jetzt hat die esa diesen antrieb absolut
revolutionär modifiziert stadt xenon
wurde während des testlaufs das edelgas
langsam durch luftmoleküle ersetzt denn
einem solchen antrieb ist es letztlich
egal mit welchen teilchen er den
rückstoß erzeugt zitat als die saison
basierte blauer farbe des triebwerk
strahlt zu violett wechselte wussten wir
dass wir es geschafft hatten das sagt
louis wallbott von der esa damit ist
tatsächlich eine neue ära der raumfahrt
angebrochen denn sie müssen ganz
unterschiedliche raumfahrzeuge kaum noch
treibstoff mitnehmen ein solcher antrieb
würde auch in einen niedrigen mars orbit
funktionär würde überall da sehr lange
missionen ermöglichen wo in irgendeiner
weise teilchen angesaugt ionisiert und
ausgestoßen werden können in der
marsatmosphäre könnte das zum beispiel
kohlendioxid seien und die elektrische
energie die für den antrieb benötigt
wird kann einfach durch die sonne
mittels solarzellen erzeugt werden eine
unerschöpfliche energiequelle rosige
zeiten brechen also für so manchen
missionen an und wir werden dadurch viel
besser erkenntnisse erzielen können die
saturnsonde cassini hätte vielleicht so
viel länger im orbit des planeten
unterwegs sein können und vielleicht
sogar durch neue experimente leben auf
enceladus nachweisen kann wenn ihr als
erstes neues zum thema raumfahrt und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
endet hier meine telefonnummer bei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr können dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion vorliegt so
mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen
oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und
mitbestimmen was ihr bei pixum passiert
der direkte draht zu mir einfach
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der genau glocke vergessen hier
geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken hat cassini außerirdisches
leben auf enceladus entdeckt ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran